is your privacy under threat has the age
of privacy come to an end
are you sick of Facebook's lack of
respect for your privacy if you think
your privacy's threatened be glad you
don't live in China Chinese government
wants to give every citizen a score
based on behavior purchase history
political leanings and social
interactions would be used to calculate
a person's trust score Facebook and
Twitter or banned in China so people use
we checked one of the world's most
popular mobile apps so the government
spies on that round-the-clock the state
also monitors the Chinese version of
Amazon called
Alibaba Alibaba is by your side 24 hours
a day seven days a week
why should we care what the Communists
do we're not in China you're walking to
the calmness voluntarily that scares me
Lee's schooling came to America thirty
years ago after I came to United States
I thought oh no more politics in the
land of free I'm not worried then after
I saw these things happened I said no no
no I said I have to tell the American
people don't let this happen here's Lee
when she was 16 she survived the Great
Leap Forward the great famine the
Cultural Revolution
her parents were doctors so they and she
were we educated Mao said we shouldn't
learn from books we should learn from
the military from the farmers from the
workers and this was to teach you not to
be fancy the poor you were the better
you are if you're illiterate you're the
best
the repression is over it's all better
now
the depressions not over the control
people's mind people's mouths people's
pen never stopped today in China if you
tell friends about certain books your
message will be blocked even innocent
sounding phrases are censored so I
understand the titles of novels like
Animal Farm brave new world but long
live the Emperor because long life means
forever xi jinping knowledge is the
constitution president forever yeah but
nobody can talk
be sure they can't even talk about this
teddy bear Winnie the Pooh oh because
somebody the pool so it's been and now
another step more subtle than just
banning things the state will monitor
what you say in social media and assign
you a social credit school that will
tell them how trustworthy you are the
government says this will allow the
trustworthy to roam everywhere under
heaven well making it hard for the
discredited to take a single step
there's going to be this new social
credit score yes it is a big deal some
American governments already do
something similar the LAPD can scan tens
of thousands of license plates
Los Angeles Police now practice
predictive policing they pay a company
called Palantir to analyze social media
trace people's ties to gang members and
predict the likelihood that someone may
commit a crime after searching over a
hundred million data points Palantir
displayed an impressive web of
information on one burglary suspect
people like that they think it makes
them safer I think they're giving
government too much power they didn't
realize there's going to be going to
leave more and more and more there's no
end I would like to know that there's a
trust score so I can know who's
trustworthy and who's not sounds sort of
appealing yes we do want to know who we
can trust when we do business but those
are market behaviors we don't need the
government to get involved when
government does get involved bad things
can happen what happens if you have a
low score first lawsuit job or you never
get promoted your children cannot get to
good schools for Chinese people if they
the kids cannot go to a good school
that's the whole world if they really
don't like what you say they lock you up
and torture you they didn't allow me to
sleep I was kept in a small room and saw
no daylight for half a year but that's
China why should we be afraid get out of
my life in America every
week on YouTube Twitter Facebook I
challenge people in power Trump does
make things up I say these things and no
one punishes me so far
you